[Musique]
on est en vogue en ce moment vers l'île
kangourou dans le sud de l'australie
c'est dans des endroits qui étaient les
plus dévastées par les feuillets de la
moitié ville que brûler 25000 koala qui
sont morts et nous on veut voir ce que
les équipes font sur le terrain en ce
moment pour aider les animaux qui ont
survécu jay style bio et son équipe de
bénévoles viennent chaque jour dans les
zones dévastées pour apporter la
nourriture aux animaux qui n'ont plus
d'un pas décidé quand on lève la tête on
aperçoit parfois des koalas mais on en
découvre aussi au sol à nos pieds rien
de tel croire pour les équipes comme
celle de justin c'est donc important de
repérer rapidement les koalas qui
peuvent encore être sauvé et les années
ici dans ce parc animalier au centre de
l'île qui s'est transformé en quelques
semaines en hôpital pourquoi là il y en
a plus de 200 sur place chacun d'entre
eux
c'est mimi brad qui s'en occupe deux
vétérinaires habitude soigner des chats
et des chiens
mais après les fouilles et sont venus
sur l'île pour traiter des coûts à la
fois comme lui qui a 4 ans qui a déjà
perdu une griffe il d'autres pourraient
tomber
on ne sait même pas si pour un jour
grimper aux arbres dans l'antre d'un
côté les poids du coup à la porte encore
les traces du brasier
il prend du poids même si ce n'est pas
toujours facile de le poser sinon des
koalas kirin mieux à l'hôpital le
problème
ou est ce qu'on met une fois qu'il sera
complètement rétabli
[Musique]
heureusement en australie la végétation
qui est habitué au fure se régénère très
rapidement mais il faudra quand même
attendre des mois au moins avant que
l'on ait suffisamment pour tous les
animaux au l'hôpital de quoi lasser donc
beaucoup de pression
il doit s'agrandir constamment et pour
des équipes comme celle de justin
elles devront rester sur le terrain
pendant des semaines encore whitney
méchoui
avec le rappel constant leur travail a
ses limites